[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
hey everybody how are you doing
uh my name is pete also knows now though
here to give you an ilp first look at a
game called witchtastic
now which tastic is a game that is very
very similar
to um to overcooked now um
the reason why we call it something
similar to overcooked is because it's
got like a more hyped up version of what
it is now um
which tastic has you take control of
which
who is learning the arts of uh
potion making
now um
throughout the whole entire time frame
when you're starting to play this game
uh you learn the little bits of ins and
outs of of how to
operate uh your witch and uh how to um
you know mix your potions
now um
the
the thing is you have this al person or
owl friend whoever you wish to call it
to um to kind of give you some insight
and kind of tell you hey this is uh how
you mix your potions is what you need to
do
now um the reason why
this is
what i feel to be a lot more difficult
uh than um
than you know uh predecessors is because
not only do you have to consistently mix
the potions
you have to get your ingredients you
have to find your ingredients uh and
even you have to get uh wood for the
fire to make sure that your your potions
your uh your cauldron stays lit now
uh over time you kind of learn uh what
you're supposed to be doing with it uh
which means you're supposed to figure
out um you know putting x y and z plants
together makes x potions ascend out
now
um
it even gives you a little bit of an
added bonus on top of that which is the
part where you actually have um
animals coming to attack you
while you're in the middle of um
starting these potions so you have to
avoid them while using your broom to fly
over things
to get wood
your your your objects on the grounds
and all this other stuff and it it is
it's a lot um
i ended up playing with my wife um
now
the
because i used at first
a keyboard and mouse and that definitely
got to the point where
it was very very hard um but once i used
the controller it was vastly easier um
i feel that if
you have you know multiple players using
controllers
this game will be easy for anyone to use
you can kind of fly through it so i
would definitely recommend you end up um
you know using that if you are planning
uh to to play this game
now
this game has is very
has very smooth artistic
views the environments are really really
cool they're very very thought out i
really really enjoyed them and i
definitely did enjoy playing that um the
out the when you complete more and more
levels you get to unlock more outfits
like new hats new colors new things like
that which makes it a lot more fun to to
end up playing so i definitely i would
like to uh thank the developers for uh
uh red for games uh for sending over
this code i greatly appreciate it uh i
really did enjoy it um
so i if you get some time and you have
uh if you enjoy those types of games you
want a more difficult type of it uh you
could definitely pick up this game um so
yes so please do that
uh my name is pete also known as naldo
here to give you an ilp first look at
uh witchtastic um my wife uh samantha
she also helped play like i said so
you'll see uh portions of the video with
her in there also i think her son
tristan was uh sitting
on her lap for a good portion of it so
yeah so it was a family event if you
will um but yes thank you very much
again um my name is pete also knows now
though i'm on twitch every monday
through friday from 3 to 11 uh so please
come check us out there um at uh senaldo
dot tv if you're looking for me there uh
also please check ilp out every single
sunday uh the ironworks podcast is an
amazing podcast about gaming about news
and very very hot topics that are
happening that week i recommend
everybody go and check that out and uh
finally if you're looking for some daily
news that are good to have please go and
check out lords of gaming.net and uh
check them out so it'd be very very uh
you know informative for you there so
thank you again
have a fantastic rest of your week and
uh bye everybody thank you
[Music]
you have fun
now
well you have to do the recipes
what's happening
so much caffeine oh it does go a lot
faster
ah where will fit me
slap you out of it
i love it i just screamed
okay
which one did you make you made the
white one
i'm gonna do the mandrake and a leaf
how did you drink it
[Music]
woods up top
watch out
[Music]
he's chasing me
you got me
you have to put that down and you slap
me
thank you
yes
[Music]
yes
don't tell
i'll anyone sure i don't tell the
developers
oh no no no no no
[Music]
oh no they're not even asking for this
[Music]
me
can i please have a ginger in my pot
that's
garlic my
i'm pot gonna be done
[Music]
you